the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
last class I talked about payment
channels and Lightning Network so today
will be today we'll talk about a bit
more about payment channels we'll recap
a little bit we'll talk about some
optimizations one of which is key
addition the other is hash trees and
then we'll talk about cross chain swaps
or cross chain atomic swaps ok so last
time the the sort of main idea of these
payment channels as you've got this
commitment transaction and each party
holds a sort of different transaction
that has you know the same amounts but
slightly different scripts so it's
spending from a shared funding
transaction and it's sending out to you
know the one that's held by Alice on her
hard drive sends to Bob in the clear
right Bob just gets his eight coins with
no ifs ands or buts
however when Alice broadcasts this she
needs to wait a hundred blocks
she needs to wait a day and if she
reveals this key to Bob now Bob can use
Bob's key in this revocable key and Bob
can get these coins immediately and the
opposite is for Bob right so when Bob
has his transaction it's got analysis
signature he doesn't store his own
because he can just create compute it
quickly the two coins that go to Alice
go to her in the clear however the eight
coins that Bob guessed for himself he
has to wait a hundred blocks and during
the hundred bucks
Alice can sign if she has Bob's
revocation key okay so that's the basic
idea of these outputs and then you
construct these so when I say you know
Alice one Bitcoin Bob nine Bitcoin it's
of the format in these right the person
who holds that transaction has a
transaction where the other party gets
the coins immediately and their own
coins have this lock lock up period and
can be grabbed by the other party
if they revoke them so initially the
state is Alice
one bitcoin bob has nine there's two
different statement transactions one
held by us one held by bomb they build a
new transaction together where Alice has
five coins and Bob has five points and
then they revoke the old one by sharing
these secrets right so now since they
both has handed each other these revoke
a ssin private keys both of these
parties cannot broadcast this if they do
the other party takes all the money
right and then you can build these
indefinitely okay so any questions about
that that was covered last time but it's
kind of in the complicated questions
good okay so some optimizations we'd
want to make yeah so basically either
party broadcast and has to wait Alice
gives Bob the alice our private key Bob
use Alice the Bravo our private key they
broadcast the counter party takes all
the funds so what are some optimizations
here the basic idea of the script is
okay key a can you know you can have a
signature from key a and you have to
wait a day or two or five or whatever or
you can have a signature from key B and
the signature from key C so what are
some optimizations here the revealing
part anyway to make that smaller more
efficient so one idea is you know
preimage instead of a signature right
you're just you're just revealing
something you're not actually committing
to any data so Bob could when Bob
reveals his secret he could just be
here's a here's a pre-image
and you can get instead of like 70 bytes
for a signature you get down to like 20
bytes for a hash and a pre-image right
because so how would it work you just
say okay Alice signs if Alice knows Bob
R's preimage right the Bob our Bob our
doesn't have to actually sign she can
just know it
that would work
so actually that was sort of the initial
idea I think that's what's written in
the paper but you can do even saw so an
even smaller way to do it is combine
keys so in the elliptic curve that we're
using and you know all these groups all
these signature schemes if you add two
keys together you can get a third key
and it's using the addition operator
operation that's defined on this group
so in the case where you have you know
key B and key C and you add them
together to get say key are what's the
private key four key are anyone you've
got TV private key key C which has a
private key you add the two public keys
up together yeah it's the sum of the
private keys right so public key B is
just private key B times the generator
Point G but in this you know C times G
equals R times G and then you can just
you know put the move the parenthesis
around so B plus C the private keys
added together times the generator point
it's still the same so this is a really
nice property actually it's sort of the
main property that we use for all
signatures and all this stuff but what
that means is you can say here I you
know I take your public key I'm gonna
compute you know come up with my own
private key compute the public key for
that add them together and say hey we've
got this new shared public key and
neither of us can sign with it yet
because we don't know each other's
private keys but if either of us reveals
the private key then the other party can
sign with it right so if this is Bob's
and this is Alice's they can both
compute little R times G by doing this
operation right they both share public
keys and compute the shared public key
but they cannot sign because neither of
them knows little R and then let's say
Alice says okay Bob here's here's this
little C gives it to Bob Bob says okay
now I know a little R
but Alex doesn't right so this is a
really nice way to do it because it
saves a lot of space so instead the
script is now just keyd oh I should have
put our oops he D or key a in time right
so instead of having this this key and
time passes or these other two keys both
sign you just have a single key that can
sign immediately or another key that can
sign after a period of time so the
actual script used is this you say up if
the key are op else delay op check
sequence verify op drop then the key a
and then the end if did not check sake
so I'll walk through this because it's a
little confusing the OP if takes an item
off the stack and it's either true or
false so the first thing you have to do
is you have to indicate which of these
two paths you're going to use right
either you're gonna put key are on the
stack or you're going to put this delay
number which is say a hundred blocks put
an option sequence verify to verify that
it has been 100 blocks since you created
the transaction you're spending and then
you have to drop the delay this was to
ensure compatibility since it's a soft
work so old knows would see this old
ones would see this they would see a no
op and then they would see the drop to
get rid of this whole thing so the old
nodes wouldn't see it at all then you
have a key a put on the stack and then
you end the if statement and then you
check signatures so really the if
statement is just determining which key
gets pushed onto the stack and then the
after the if statement there's a check
sig you know to check the signature from
that key so for example if you're using
the revocation key the key that has been
combined and revealed to you you just
put a 1 on the stack and then a
signature from R and the OP if results
the true so it executes this by just
pushing the key onto the stack then it
executes soph else skips to op end it
and then just stop checks it
right so basically you say one execute
off if PR skip to check sig so it's just
you need to sign with this key or you
say zero and signature form a and then
so the Optive takes a zero it skips to
op else because it's you know not true
it performs
you know pushes delay on to the on to
the stack performs check sequence verify
to make sure that enough time has passed
drops the delay number off the stack
which is a little ugly it would be nicer
if object sequence verified did that
itself but it doesn't then pushes key a
on to the stack you know ends the if
statement and checks the signature so
it's a little more complicated than like
in C where you just can say like you
know PD or key a and time but this is
stack based and it's it's not too hard
when you get these things work so any
questions about this setup yes drop
takes the topmost item on the stack and
deletes it and all the little lower
items come back up yeah it it's just so
that compatibility wise there would be
ways to since objects weakens verify
basically this used to be a no op where
it did nothing and then the soft fork
was okay we're redefining no op three I
believe two objects check sequence
verify where it looks at basically the
age of your inputs and how you know how
many confirmations your inputs have had
or really the specific input you're
spending in this case old nodes would
just see it as a no op and so you could
put something like delay options
sequence verify and then an opcode
around here that says make sure the type
top item on the stack is greater than
five and if this consumed the delay
value I mean by taking it off the stack
the old nodes might say oh this is
invalid even though this is a no op the
the subsequent op code causes this to
fail whereas in the new version
it would be like no this is good because
this consumes that value and that would
actually make it a hard fork because
then there would be transactions where
the old nodes thought it was not good
and the new nodes thought yes this is
okay so to ensure that this only
restricts the the validity of scripts it
doesn't pop that off so you have to
manually drop it and drop is there from
before so to an old old node it would
just say delay no op drop and was like
okay you put something in the stack you
do nothing and then you take it off the
stack fine so that's just a
compatibility thing if you are gonna
make it from scratch you'd probably do
it different other questions about this
okay cool so okay so then you reveal
keys right you keep revealing things
each time you make a new state and you
can do these several times a second
right you can do it ten times a second
something like that so you can have
millions billions of different old
transactions the problem is you do have
to remember all of these old private
keys that your counterparty is given to
you because if you forget one they might
broadcast a transaction where you really
need to know that private key in order
to grab the money immediately right so
if you forget for example you forget
this was revoked but you forgot about it
and you're Alice and then Bob broadcasts
this you really need to know that
private key so you can grab bombs five
coins with your you know combined key so
you need to keep track of all these old
things
so it's 32 bytes each it's not great for
scalability so there's actually a couple
ways you could do this how can you
remember a chain of 32 byte secrets a
Merkle tree itself would have a root
here and then a bunch of little hashes
that go up to the tree that the trees
root so if these were secrets you can't
go back down right so you feel like okay
I got secret zero secret
secret - secret three well I've got the
parents of these two things but I can't
actually remember them any better
so the simple at like a real simple way
say okay I've got and you can construct
it however you want
right obviously if your counterparty is
not cooperating and these these secret
numbers are just completely random
there's nothing you can do right if you
just says hey I'm gonna give you secret
zero secret one secret - there's no you
know special properties about these
things I can't do anything
the simplest way what's what's a real
simple way to say okay I'm gonna reveal
secrets sequentially and then you can
store fewer of them it's sort of like a
blockchain right so you could just say
okay well I create secret three secret
two is the hash of secret three secret
one is the hash of secret - and so now I
reveal one you don't know what two is
you know and so on so 0 equals hash of 1
so you can just have a linear chain like
this right so 0 1 2 3 if you remember 3
you can compute 2 & 1 & 0 if you
remember - you can compute 1 & 0 but not
3 so you can do that that would actually
probably work fine but we always want to
make unnecessary complex optimizations
to things so this would be the problem
with this is if you've got a billion of
them and you need to go back to the
first one you need to compute a billion
hash operations that's kind of slow so
what we do or what the basic idea
there's like multiple implementations
slight variations yeah but hash tree so
you reveal secrets one at a time you
store only log n secrets and you
recompute any secret you want with
something around login operation I
called it L chrome I think there's an
actual paper that basically is this
called GG M that's like I think we
written by people at MIT but I called it
L chrome because it
Merkle tree backwards because the arrows
point the other direction so in this
case if you want you start with a root
you start with some you start with
something up here and you say okay if I
want to descend to the left I append a
zero to the value of this you know the
hash value in this root and I hash to
get that and if I want to go right I
append a one at the end hash that I'm
gonna go down here so what that lets you
do is there's a sender and a receiver
the sender just computes a root and
stores that you know they make a random
root up story and then they also keep
track of okay how many secrets have I've
given the receiver just receives the
first one you know number zero I can't
do anything they received one okay still
can't do anything they received two now
they can say okay well I can throw away
0 and 1 because if I want to compute 0
and 1 I can just store too and if I
won't understand to the left append a
zero and hash if I want to send it right
so you know I don't store these but I
know they're still computable for me if
I ever want to grab them back again I
received 3 can't do anything or a suit
for can't do anything receive 5 now I
can do the same thing with 3 & 4 remove
those from the disk and only store 2 & 5
so if I get a request for 3 I can easily
compute it and then I receive 6 and I
can delete those 2 as well right so as I
go up the tree sometimes they only have
to store one thing sometimes I have to
store 3 things because that's the height
of the tree well it's basically you have
to store at most one on every level and
then sometimes two for there two leaves
so basically log in storage and
computing hashes is pretty quick too so
that's a fun way to only have to store a
very you know small amount of data okay
any questions about this okay so we're
going quick
hmm okay we need an intermission it's
quick okay so we'll talk about cross
chain squats for most the bulk of this
day
so there are alt coins I mostly work on
Bitcoin I think a lot of the research is
on Vic one but there's a lot of
different coins - people saw the idea of
Bitcoin and said hey let's copy it so
initially most of them were just copies
right there was a site called coin
gendai so like 2012 there started to be
a lot of all coins like litecoin and - :
and things like that
and most of them were like real small
changes where they took the the Bitcoin
source code on github and they changed a
couple numbers here and there and they
said okay well it's a new coin and then
blue map made a site called coin Ginetta
yo where you could do it all very easily
for people who work programming savvy
they could just make their own altcoin
buy menus like there's a website you say
I want it to be called touch going I
want there to be 25 coins every three
minutes and I want that you know just a
bunch of things you could upload a
little picture and it would make a it
would make a program for you based on
those things and then I think he sold
the site it was I think it was like the
first blockchain technology companies
Farzin okay so then recent ones are very
different people trade all coins for
bitcoins and trade all coins for all
coins and they use exchanges I don't
know if have have people hear used
exchanges to trade alt coins some okay I
actually have I hadn't until last year
but there was these like sort of hard
Forks from Bitcoin like the coin cash
and becoming gold and making whatever
and so I actually open an accountant and
sold them and got more bitcoins how do
you trade well use an exchange and so
the current exchange model pretty much
without fail is give us all your coins
post orders on our site to swap with
other users and then ask for your coins
back so we give us all your coins part
it works fine right they give you an
address you send your coins to their
address
and you know it'll appear on their site
generally but but you definitely can
send your coins the ask for your coins
back is where the model tends to fail
there's many many cases where they don't
give them back and and there's a lot of
reasons for this that just so you know
Mount GOx is one of the one of the most
prominent early ones but it certainly
wasn't the first well there was a okay
probably one of the first was called my
bitcoins calm and then it was sort of it
I don't know if it was intentional but
the joke after was like well it's his
bitcoins now it's just it was more of a
web wallet that had private keys than a
actual exchange but a lot of these
exchanges you know they're really easy
to set up you just write some software
and people start sending you coins and
then a lot of either there's like
internal problems where you've got some
rogue employee or the rogue employee is
the only employee and someone just
realizes hey this computer in front of
me has 20 million dollars worth of stuff
on it like I think I'll just unplug it
and keep all the money
also hackers right because they're
probably the best targets for you know
trying to intrude and hack into a system
that you can find because there's a
whole ton of money on this computer it's
not like data or oh I get some ones you
know Facebook pictures or I get
someone's credit card numbers like yeah
that's nice but bitcoins are you know
sort of money and you steal okay so
other problems with the exchange model
is that people tend to trust it a lot
and they think well this is you know
they assume that it's like a bank and
banks are very trustworthy because in
recent memory there haven't really been
big failures at least in this country so
they sort of carry that trust forward
bad things happen so the idea is
wouldn't it be cool if we could have
cross chain swaps where we have some
kind of way where I've got a bunch of
coin a you've got a bunch of coin B and
we can swap between them without giving
custody to some third party or even
giving custody to each other so you can
do this using hash time
contracts just like in the lightning
Network right so you get this coin if
and only if I get this other coin you
want them to be atomic you don't even if
it's very quick you don't want any
period of time in which one party has
all the assets or more of the assets so
the interesting thing is about this is
the Lightning Network sort of does this
already right the Lightning Network is a
way to make atomic payments between
different channels and then if you look
at these channels and say well does the
channel do the channels have to be on
the same coin do they have to be the
same blockchain and basically no not
much difference has to happen for they
used to be different for it for them to
be different block chains okay so it's
this is the hdl-c slide from last time
it's similar in that you have these two
outputs right the same as in a regular
lightning payment channel that's at rest
Alice gets so for example Bob holds this
where if you broadcast this Alice gets
two coins right off the bat Bob needs to
wait a hundred blocks or two no or Alice
can know Bob's replication key and she
can get seven coins or he gets the seven
coins and then you've got this hdl-c
hash time lock contract where alice
needs to know a pre-image or say well
yeah Alice needs to know R this this
receipt and or Bob has to wait but the
difference in waiting is this is a
relative time lock so that Bob has to
wait a hundred blocks after he
broadcasts this transaction right
whereas in this case Bob has to wait
until height 500000 regardless of when
he broadcasts this transaction so it may
be that he can broadcast this
transaction and immediately spent by
signing here because that that time has
passed so it seems like a small
distinction but it's actually pretty
important for this to be just absolute
time so that's how an HPLC works right
this this output this outputs Alice's no
no question this output should be Bob's
and by should I mean like something's
gone wrong something
pretty seriously wrong if Alice takes
this money right this only is due to
fraud and fraud is not like an illegal
to find sense but we sort of can think
of you know basically this is always
gonna be Alice's this is approximately
always going to be Bob's this one we're
really not sure right this can fail and
it's not due to any malice this good
this can this can sort of it should be
Alice's right you're trying to pay Alice
here but it may well be the case that
Bob takes it back and that's not due to
fraud that's just due to computers
crashing or networks not working right
or something like that you know this can
sort of innocently be broadcast and go
back to Bob where's this can't really
any questions about the hdl-c
basic idea okay so you need you know
Alice needs to know this secret or bob
has to wait until a certain time okay so
the cross chain swaps is basically the
same as a route in payment in lightning
right before we said okay Alice has a
channel with Bob Bob has a channel with
Carol and now Alice wants to pay Carol
without opening a new channel in the
case of lightning where it's all on the
same block chain
Alice could open a payment channel to
Carol and spend directly that way in the
case where these two are different block
chains you can't actually do that right
you can't say oh I'm going to you know
there's no define the channel that will
link to different block chains okay the
other aspect is although this can work
with three parties in the case of swaps
you're generally not saying hey Bob
I will pay you five dos coins if you pay
Carol 100 Verte cones
you're usually saying if you pay me on
advert clients right so yeah
usually it's Alice sending to Bob who's
sending back to Alice it still works
if this is the third party Carol but it
sort of doesn't make as much sense
because generally you're saying hey I'll
give you this if you give me that okay
so in this case we have two different
blocks you know we've actually reduced
the number of parties where it's just
Alice and Bob but we've got two
different block chains we got dos going
which i think is like yellow right and
then Bert cone is like green
you can't Oh cuz they don't up segue
well say dogecoin upgrades pretty soon
so you could but it's you'd have to
write a lot of code to deal with that
yeah to us it's way easier to just merge
it yeah just upgrades who who's in
charge of doge tell them the upgrade so
a lot of these all coins they sort of
you can they've sort of archaeological
aspects to them where you can see where
they branched off of the main Bitcoin
code base because a lot of times they
don't get updated because no one's
really working on them this fight no one
really working on them or looking at
them they can still be worth a billion
dollars as I think Doge was a few months
ago but so sometimes they catch up and
you're like oh let's let's take all the
code from Bitcoin that they've developed
from the last few years and apply it
sometimes the opposite happens where an
altcoin will make something cool and
people in Bitcoin will merge it in but
it's generally the opposite direction
okay so you've got these two channels
that have been set up and Alice wants to
sell her dogecoin and by berkland so you
have the same hdl-c construction where
alice what's interesting in this case
that it's the same person on the both
sides so there's actually some
optimizations you can do but forget
those for a second Alice computes a
random number R hashes it to make H she
sends it to herself which doesn't really
make any sense in this case so you can
skip that stuff
Alice already knows H and already knows
are so yeah but but Alice doesn't have
to be Alice right it could be Carol
so there's optimizations that you can do
when they're the same person but anyway
okay so she constructs an HDL C to Bob
it says okay if Bob knows our he gets
this money otherwise Alice gets it after
five o'clock Bob says okay
I don't know R so I can't get these
douche ones Bob then forwards it to
Alice and saying okay if Alice knows our
she gets the coins if Bob waits till
after four o'clock he gets the coins so
it's sort of like why make this this
construction it actually still makes a
sense because even though Bob knows that
Alice knows our Alice we'll have to
reveal our in order to take the coins
right so it's saying okay you need to
know our and you need to not just know
our but you have to show everyone
because the the actual script says okay
you need to know the preimage of this
20-byte hash and when you actually spend
you have to put that preimage in the
blockchain right you have to put it in
your input for your transaction and then
bob can see it so the idea is if alice
closes this channel invert coin takes
the coins by using our Bob we'll know
our and Bob will know it's the same R
that he can use to take the coins on the
dogecoin network okay so you add these
two H DLCs you then
clear them out so Alice instead of
instead of revealing our on the
blockchain I also can just real reveal
our directly to Bob I'm saying okay I'm
clearing out this hdl-c because here's
our you know that I can do this
so just give me the coins you also know
R so you can take the coins yourself if
I don't cooperate on that end but
hopefully she does so then you get rid
of the hdl-c
now it's back down to two outputs there
and then Bob says okay I've I've lost
the Verte coin and I haven't really
gotten the the dogecoin yet but I know I
can close the channel I'm taking it if
need be and then Bob goes to Alice she
already knows are but look like you know
that I know R let's clear this and then
Alice can just send the coins that way
okay so any questions about this setup
yes
yeah well that's why you have different
times here right so so yes that is
possible that you could get to this step
and then Alice goes offline and shuts
the channels down you know closes the
channels but the idea is that bob has
Bob can can grab these coins back after
4 p.m.
whereas Alice has to wait until 5:00
p.m. to grab these coins back so if
Alice closes and tries to wait till
right at right before 4 p.m. and then
immediately grab these coins
Bob's actually okay because Bob says
okay well you grab the rare coins but I
actually have another hour until I have
to you know I have an hour to reveal our
where you're not able to get these coins
back so that so having this incrementing
time can help against that there's
there's it's it's um yeah an hour is
probably not enough there's the the
trade-offs to having these times is if
you have it very far in the future with
very large gaps those hdl-c you can get
stuck there and if Alice just says look
I'm leaving this third output in the
transaction that can be annoying or if
it you know get stuck on chain it might
take a long time to get it back but so
you want it long enough times that you
don't worry about these timing attacks
where someone you know immediately
broadcasts and now you only have an hour
and maybe the blockchain is congested
versus the annoyance of oh it closed and
now I have to wait until 5:00 p.m. so
those are the trade-offs there any other
questions okay
okay so
cross-chain swaps right H can reveal be
revealed
sorry R well H this goes into either
chain ours then revealed on either chain
so that both parties needs to watch both
both parties need to watch both block
chains this sort of makes sense right in
that the channels are on two different
block chains and both parties have a
channel on each so the receiver doesn't
need to be initiator so like it doesn't
have to be Alice on both sides but in
most cases I think it probably will be
so yeah you know Alice has a vertical
channels also has doeskin dogecoin
channel as does Bob so they need to be
operating on both networks there are
possibilities where if you've had say
this was Carol and she sent to Dave
using litecoin so if you have Alice Bob
Carol dave doge Verte coin litecoin
alice would not have to know about
anything but those coin right so you
actually only have to worry about the
networks that you're you have channels
in even though there are secrets that
could appear in other well no sorry
that's not true
you'll have to so if this is Carol Alice
does have to look at vertically because
the vertical network could good sure
thing so you have to look at one
additional chain right so that's that's
one of the issues with cross chain swaps
where you may you know you may be
routing through a network that you're
not aware of essentially I don't think
that's that likely in practice right so
like it could be I'll send you five
Jewish coins if you send her 20 light
coins and then you send back douche
coins to this other place but it's
possible yes
yes and then if that's Carol let's say
Alice hey Carol
yeah right Carol receives very :
Alice loses those points there's an
exchange okay yeah so like you go to
some other kind you know you go to you
know England you pay with your credit
card you lose dollars but they get
pounds and there's some somehow there's
an exchanger in the middle right and so
from Bob's perspective it works the same
either way he's getting more dogecoins
and losing for clothes right right so
it's possible that you set up this by
initially funding it so Alice says I
have a ton of dogecoins Alice creates
this channel and she has like 100 doge
coins and bob has zero and same with
vertical bob could have a lot of them
and say okay I have 20 Verdeans and
Alice has zero and then we can make
those payments in that direction you can
pay them you know so so actually in all
the software now I think there's only
single funded channels because having
both parties funded at the same time is
kind of its software-wise a little
harder and it's also like interface why
it's gonna become complicated because
how do you know when to match someone's
funding right so so usually what you do
is you say I'm an Alice hey Bob what's
your public key you know give me a new
public key
okay I'm gonna construct this channel
here sign this and Bob's like okay and
Bob has like nothing no money at stake
when this process happens and then Bob
also creates the channel with Alice
saying okay I'm gonna put a bunch of our
coin in this channel and they usually
start with all the money on one side so
they can then trade another question
that's good
yeah so they have to look at these
different channels on different block
chains in order to make sure this works
there's still a lot of open questions
here how do you actually trade like this
is
really good for trade execution but what
about discovery so the current exchanges
they're not just you know put all your
money in here there's and then ask for
it back there's that middle step where
like you find all the other parties so
post the orders on the blockchain and
maybe there's problems I mean it's it's
not too crazy an idea but there's some
problems with it right if you just say
hey I want to sell dogecoins and I want
to buy Bourke wins and you sort of put
that in an opera turn on the blockchain
well it's non-binding right you don't
have to actually do anything they can be
front-running where the orders can go
and you know the wrong sequence are in
time and it's not scalable because if
everyone's posting orders on the
blockchain that can take up a lot of
space probably more so than actual
transactions I don't know what I mean
I'm sure it may be like total number of
orders placed on a order book versus
total number of actual order executions
usually it's there's a lot more orders
that then end up getting canceled
because in most exchanges that I've seen
and I believe this is the case in like
you know regular New York Stock Exchange
kind of things you can say hey I want to
sell this at this price and then a few
minutes later you say yeah I changed my
mind I don't want to sell it at that
price anymore the price has moved and
I've changed my mind
and a lot of times yeah yeah about 1% of
the actual trades getting it executed
yeah that sounds probably about the same
as in a lot of Bitcoin exchanges usually
in the Bitcoin exchanges they don't
charge you to you know post it post at
you know an order and then take it back
that's free whereas the trade actually
executing usually they have some kind of
fee so posting the orders themselves on
the blockchain seems like a cool idea
but but you know you've got now the
scalability problem with all these
transactions now it's probably a hundred
times worse because you're all and
front-running could also be tricky
because the blockchain does provide
sequence and timing but it's up to the
miners so if you have a ten minute
window during that 10 minute the window
the miners can basically shuffle things
around however they want and so if the
miner is also trading they can see oh I
see all these different orders I will
match these orders and let those happen
afterwards so this is an issue so
there's a bunch of different models
people are looking at and to be clear
here this is not something that really I
don't to say it doesn't exist yet it
sort of does there are these
decentralized exchanges popping up
mostly on the etherium network right now
because then it's not actually cross
chain you can have cross asset because
there's all these ERC 20 tokens but the
cross chain swaps themselves are a bit
more complicated to program so I don't
know of any like you know live not main
net operation like this so one model
would be you have a central order book
and a central counterparty so the
exchange says okay we're still the
exchange we still have a website we
still have order you know buys and sells
and stuff like that and not only that
but the exchange is one side of every
trade so they say okay open a channel
with us put all your verticals in put
all your dogecoins in and then we'll
open a different channel with you and
we'll put like coins in it and if you
you trade with us but then what they can
do is they can say well we're not
actually going to trade unless there's
some someone else performing a similar
you know opposite trade and then they
can keep the spread so they say okay
we're selling vert corn at this rate and
buying it at this other slightly
different rate so that seems the most
feasible I would venture that that's
going to happen first because it's not
too crazy but it has similar
centralization to the current model
right but there is less counterparty
risk so if you are worried about an
exchange shutting down and running off
with all your dogecoin this can help
right say okay well I have a channel
with my doge going in it and a channel
with my vert point in it and I can sell
some Deutsch going get some berkland
from the exchange and I still have a
nice order but it doesn't solve any kind
of front-running problem right the
exchange can still order things how they
want and the exchange can still shut
down but it's much more difficult for
the exchange to somehow steal your coins
which is a problem in another model you
say well we have a central order book
right so the exchange still exists and
aggregates all the orders of everyone
who wants to buy and sell but there's
multiple counterparties that you
interact with directly so the exchange
says okay i'm ii and i will tell Alice
about Bob right Alice says hey I want to
sell those going in by vertical at this
rate and then the exchange tells Alice
and Bob okay you guys matched right Bob
you wanna you want to sell vertical
analysis performed this trade this is
cooler but there's questions in that
like if you're connecting to many
counterparties it's costly right you
have to open a new channel and that is
on chain also how do you enforce trade
execution right if it's if it's a trade
on a current exchange and you say okay I
want to buy bitcoins and you click OK it
just happened right there aren't they
aren't even your bitcoins you don't
really have control of them so when you
say you want to do something they
actually execute it in this case if they
don't have a channel with you they just
are observing the trade occur right so
they're they're saying okay I'll you
know Alice and Bob do this
why not it might not even be possible to
enforce you'd have to have some kind of
penalties if Bob says hey Alice said she
was going to sell but then didn't or Bob
complaints things like that so this
there's a lot of ideas here right
another is okay if you're if you're
building channels each channel that you
builds has these Unchained costs and
takes quite a bit of time so maybe you
could have a multi hop network from
different coins right so instead of just
Alice Bob Alice you've got you know Dave
and Carol and and as long as I'm
connected to someone in this network I
can route payments to them and they can
route payments to me via different
channels so I'm connected to this like
multi coin Network kind of mesh that
would be really cool it's not
implemented it's not even really
researched that well yet so these are
these are sort of ideas but that would
be really cool then you wouldn't need as
much liquidity so one of the issues with
the central counterparty model is the
exchange still needs to have a bunch of
money they still need to have a bunch of
dogecoins invert coins in order to be a
counterparty to every trade and then the
question is well where do those come
from right and if they say if you say oh
well it comes from customers well now
that's back into the custodial model
where they still have coins that aren't
really theirs you can say well they
probably and what I'm guessing is gonna
happen is they're gonna say well we
charge a spread and will accept
investors and so if you want to invest
in this exchange you know give us a
bunch of dogecoin give us a bunch of her
coin we will then use it to trade with
different parties and then we'll keep
some kind of spread and then hey you got
like a return on your invested dogecoin
you get more dogecoin at the end and
then you couldn't withdraw it I think
this is still better than the current
model where you leave a whole bunch of
coins on the exchange and you get
nothing
now you can choose okay do I want to
give them my coins and take that
counterparty risk but I get
return in order in exchange for that
risk or do I just want to trade without
comic party risk so another problem with
that model but it's probably what this
doesn't have that issue in that there is
no central counterparty who needs to
have a bunch of coins I'm trading
directly with the people who want who
owned the coins and want to say so yes
over the not even long term medium term
these as a use user interface they look
the same right because whether it's the
exchange itself saying okay I'm
aggravated
you know everyone deposit I've got a ton
of capital I'm gonna be a counterparty
of these trades and market maker versus
oh there's no defined market maker but
the people with a lot of money or who
are really trying to do this end up in
that position I guess the only
difference is in this case the
counterparty is also running the order
book and in this case they may be
different right there's there's an order
book server and then there's this big
counterparty who has a ton of money
who's doing all the trades so does that
difference does that make much a
difference yes first model has the
centralized
rats because they're centralized which
is kind of interesting yeah yeah so this
this probably ends up with a small
number of pretty big notes because
mostly because the efficiency right if
you're connecting to a hundred different
counterparties and you never actually
trade with any of them it's very costly
to build those channels and which I
probably has analogies to in real life
it's costly to maintain these you know
relationships with all these different
companies and stuff it's much more
efficient if we just all meet under this
button wintry it's different issue in
that you know enforcing trade execution
you might not have legal you know you
might not know who any of these people
are legally so you have some kind of
penalties or some kind of proofs that a
trade occurred the correct way things
like that the example is before you okay
so the ampoules Alice says Alice goes to
a server right so so you have an
exchange but this exchange is only the
order book right so there's a little buy
and sell kind of things and then Alice
says okay I want to I want to buy veetc
and then this is Alice Bob says okay I
want to buy what was it that was going
then the exchange says oh you guys
crossed right you want to buy veut Quine
at a rate that he's willing to sell at
or slightly higher or whatever so trade
right so the exchange tells both people
hey you matched now you have to trade
and then as soon as a sees oh you
matched you have to trade Alice
disappears it says oh I didn't want I
didn't mean to right so so the exchange
only can provide information they can't
actually force Alice and Bob to do the
trade is the problem
so that yeah in this at least in Bitcoin
I don't know how to do that because you
need to know who your counterparty is in
order to either use these channels or
even if it were on chain right you have
to share these secret you know like it's
interactive with your counterparty so at
least in Bitcoin I don't know a way to
say Alice's posting her by Verte coin
you know order in a way that anyone can
then go and fill it without additional
interactivity from Alice there might be
I think there's ways to do that in
aetherium for aetherium tokens and and
there are people who've written software
like that but in the Bitcoin model there
might be a way to do it we haven't
figured it out so so it's sort of you
know you put in your orders they return
and say okay trade and now yeah now they
have to continue to interact so it's
pretty straightforward for Bob or I'll
you know I'll so just unplug her
computer right at that point and that
that introduces timing sort of issues
where Alice just puts in all these fake
trades maybe they're kind of out there
but sometimes the market moves during
the time between I put my trade in and
the the execution comes back and so I
unplugged most of them you know I ignore
most of them but the ones that are
beneficial actually go through with well
yeah so yeah so it's I don't yeah
executable another step yeah beautiful
right so this is a new form of spoofing
of the US right it's I guess so hot in
this case would be if Bob gets Bob
if Alice's offer contains all the
information needed by Bob to execute the
trade then it would be sort of hot in
that sense and that Bob doesn't have to
interact with Alice anymore to execute
with these construction you know with
the the cross chain and swaps using
these channels you still have to talk to
each other right Bob needs to you know
Alice Bob generates no Alice generates
the r-value shares the hash with Bob you
know they're talking to each other so we
don't know if someone figures out a cool
way to do it then great that will solve
this issue but yeah
or are they believed zero SX is from
what I've read I don't know about how
real our raid remember that is radar
relay works but zero X yeah the you post
you use basically your order is
executable by any party without further
input from you but it also has scaling
issues so that's a good segue to the
next part which is having some kind of
distributed order book where there is no
central order book there is no central
counterparty the whole thing is a big
mesh network kind of thing that would be
really cool that seems the furthest out
in terms of how do you do this I mean
people are working on it but it seems
hard to make practical in that how do
you ensure fairness right who's ordering
these things and you could say well the
blockchain is ordering things these
things but that ends up being that the
miners order it so if alice is by Verte
coin she's like okay I'm buying Burgoyne
at a price of five and then he says okay
I'll buy dosh at a price of whatever you
know basically you cross and you have an
order where there's some kind of overlap
the miner can say okay well I'll instead
ignore this order execute my own and
then execute that with this guy and take
the spread because the miner really gets
to sequence things however they want
right the blockchain does provide
ordering but at the block level within a
block it's totally up to the miner so
the miners could swap things around but
yeah how do you ensure fairness in terms
of timing how do you enforce trade
execution and probably the biggest for a
distributor or a book is just the
scalability of the orders you probably
don't want to put all the orders on the
blockchain because it just ends up being
a ton of data so you have to have some
kind of broadcast network where you've
got these orders they probably should
have some way to expire but an x3 is
also an issue in that how do you make
how do you ensure that hey I'm
cancelling this order how do you ensure
that the cancellation actually
propagates
if if someone can say okay I've got
pretty good control the network and I
can just block these order cancellations
and wait and then execute so this is
sort of there's papers there's ideas but
it's kind of out there okay so that's
basically you know that was it a little
earlier but yeah this was basically the
stuff for today um the idea works right
the cross stream swaps but there's still
a lot of issues in terms of okay how do
you actually get these to work how do
you build a scalable trading platform
and there aren't really any yet there
are some some things on aetherium that
work okay
the fees end up being kind of high and
that's also aetherium where it's it's
not between different block chains right
it's all running on the etherium network
and the etherium network allows you to
specify well this is actually something
else this isn't ether you can do that in
Bitcoin but so there there are protocols
in Bitcoin like Omni and master coins
and things where you could sort of
create different assets by using up
return and basically all of those have
moved to aetherium now because it was
mutton he theorems a much nicer design
for those things and most of the Bitcoin
developers are sort of like great now
all these non Bitcoin transaction data
are have left and Bitcoin is just
focused on moving Bitcoin around yes so
the basic idea works there's still a lot
of unsolved questions further research
required which is great to hear when
you're a researcher and there's people
working on this here I'm working with a
MN student on cross chain swaps this
semester there's other people working on
all sorts of decentralized exchange
things Mei how it's also very interested
in it so if you want to work with me huh
that's a chance and yeah I think it'll
be big right because if you if you look
at these exchanges there's a lot of
profit so like I don't know a year or
two ago you look at like Polonia X they
were making like a million dollars a day
just there's so much volume and they
have very few employees so and and
they're likely like I think that the
market is getting sort of more
established now in terms of it's gonna
be larger players and stuff like that
but it was pretty much like wild wild
west a few years ago we're just like I'm
gonna open the exchange and I don't even
need a bank account the the big
exchanges that have bank accounts I feel
like are less profitable so like
coinbase
makes a lot of revenue but they have a
lot of fees like a lot of costs they
have a ton of employees they have a ton
of lawyers they have to worry about
banks whereas if you're like Polonia
Axwell Polonius is now yeah it lasted
for like a year to where they could do
that
but if you're just some random altcoin
exchange you don't need a bank account
right you say look I just I'm an
exchange where you can trade dogecoin
invert claim and that's it
there's no dollars involved so they
those kind of places they can open up on
any server anywhere in the world they
don't even need to be companies they can
just be someone server and that you know
the fact that they have custody means
they keep you know getting shut down or
just running off with money like crypts
Eatwell cripsy was that guy right so and
then he like said I remember there was a
blog post where he just sort of said he
did that and it was just like it was
just an amazing blog post where it's
like wait you're just admitting to like
a whole bunch of crimes here like you
probably shouldn't have written this and
then he like fled to China but I think
they got him he's in jail now or
something anyway so so there's a lot of
you know pretty bad actors in the
exchange space it's not well-run
generally but but it there's enormous
amounts of profit
which to me seems like in an efficiency
right wait why are these people making a
million dollars a day for something that
you know it's sort of just running
automatically on this computer that
seems like
you know right for disruption and so
there's a lot of people interested in
okay how do we decentralize the
exchanges make them like less you know
less trust involved less risk involved
and probably make less money than
baloney acts or okay coin or whatever
but that's sort of better because in
exchange where there's less
profitability means more people are
gonna want to trade on it because
there's lower fees so there's a lot of
research into this I think it's pretty
cool
I actually so next to next class on
Wednesday I'll talk about discrete log
contracts which share some of these
issues in that you know you know it's a
different way to execute a trade but it
doesn't really define how you find
people to execute that trade I
personally am more interested in the
discrete log contract stuff probably
because I you know came up with it but
also because I'm not that excited about
all coins in general I don't know people
like all coins but they I don't like
really feel the like oh we need to have
like all these different all coins that
sort of act like money I don't know
which is mostly what cross chain swaps
let you do so the discrete log contracts
so has the same issues with how do you
find each other and in it it's mostly a
scalability thing right you can do this
sort of OTC where you talk in a chatroom
and you sort of know each other and you
trade that way and that's the level it
is right now but how to scale it up it's
another question